we are still talking about gwen stefani
and blake shelton's romantic
wedding after the couple tied the knot
at the country stars
oklahoma ranch on july 3rd
that's right gwen recently shared
details from their picture-perfect day
admitting it was one of the greatest
moments of her life and now her new
husband is opening up for the first time
about the romantic song he wrote for
gwen and if fans will eventually be able
to hear it one day
i had written a song and as soon as i
knew that that's what we were going to
do
i started trying to write a song because
that's kind of the opposite of of what
she would have expected me to do because
i
i'm to the point where i just don't
write that many songs anymore it's just
like pulling teeth for me and it's
something she's
she's always on my case about it and and
she's just beats me up about it
constantly
i should write you know and so i started
writing this song
and uh and i could only get so far with
it because i
i didn't want it to just be something
for that moment i wanted to be
something that was was bigger and i so i
needed help and so i called
craig craig wiseman so yeah you gotta
help me with this thing
like i'm not joking around here you know
she didn't know i was gonna do that and
so i surprised her with with the song
and uh we actually just recorded
the song here in nashville yesterday i
don't know what or when we're going to
do something with it but it's something
that i wanted to have a recording of
no matter what you know what i'm saying
i mean it has to be an interesting
decision to make it's like at what point
is this just
our song or is this the one we share i i
think it's something i want to share
because i'm really proud of it i'm i
you know to me a marriage a ceremony
is you're not keeping it private when
you get married to somebody you're
announcing to the world hey
this is my wife just so everybody knows
that's why we wear these rings you know
this is
we're together now and i feel that way
about the song it's like
it is a uh you know for me uh
something that i want people to hear and
and know and
because i'm i'm proud to be married to
gwen and so proud of that song
to each their own i know it's your
relationship you want to make it as
public as possible
but for their coupling it's a bit much
you know we've seen them kind of pay
tribute to each other show a lot of pda
it's not my own personal preference
sometimes it's a little it's a little
like
okay um this is a bit much sometimes you
gotta keep things private
sometimes you want to share it i get it
they're musicians but
uh this reminds me of just it's
triggering me to high school again you
know those couples are like hey we're
the
couple we wrote a song for each other
like
please no i don't want to be the awkward
bird
i mean you never wrote a song for
someone i know
i'm kidding if i if i even approached
writing a song for my wife she'd be like
what are you doing
what are you doing oh my god why are you
doing this carlos you need to do you
need to write a song
omg carlos i think you should write it
just go like this
the whole time like never faced no you
know
i'll play ukulele whatever you want on
the back side you could sing and
now we could totally serenade her like
this oh my god we need to do this
listen it's always been a dream of mine
to have someone serenade me i don't know
why
it's never happened really and i think
we should do it no
wait wait wait wait so you've it's been
your dream to have someone serenade you
so you want to serenade somebody else
let's talk to sam i will do your
appetite
i was part of a barbershop quartet in
high school called the temptations
and we sang romantic covers so
maybe i could poop you know get the band
back together and uh
sing you a song the temptations
yeah we were all asian and i don't know
why
i love that i love it but i love it yeah
i would love that i would love that and
i i'm glad they're sharing their song
it's about their love
you know it could be a hit song and
someone can use it for their wedding day
and have the same feelings and you know
they're just so happy and loved guys
love is love i want to be serenaded you
know that'll be
it you know that'll be it it'll be it'll
be a wedding day first dance hit for
sure
you've got a lot of comments here
talking about it carla says
release the song blake if he feels
comfortable to do so
um yeah she also says release she says
release the song carlos
carla i haven't written anything i've
written anything yet
no one wants me to listen we have a
figure we have a thing here
we gotta do it um lw says
writing a song is romantic but if you're
a songwriter it seems like more pressure
i get that well
that's a thing too imagine you're
writing a song for someone who's also a
musician and a songwriter an
artist are you is it just pure enjoyment
that you expect or are you kind of
nervous that they're going to listen and
go
um you really rhymed that word with that
word
he did mention he did get help with the
song right he felt it sounds like he
felt the pressure he wanted to be
perfect right so
uh yeah i'm sure you do especially if
it's for gwen but
i mean if you're writing it for your
wife you shouldn't feel the pressure
wait for my life i'm just putting out
there i'm just saying in general if
you're writing a song for your wife
there should be no pressure this is
going to somehow turn into me
petitioning blake to write a song for my
wife
that's how this is going to work oh yeah
there's oh the petition numbers are out
it's
1.5 million it's 1.5 million for that
for you to write that song
as long as the temptations perform it as
long as it's performed by the
temptations